this is the home of the acacia block
Crips one of LA's smaller gangs they've
survived the brutality and clever
alliances with larger gangs
[Music]
this man's name is poop a Katia's 30
year old leader the hood he runs lies
just 10 blocks from compensate school
like the heart of the hood right here we
hang at it's dotted get arrested at
shoot people whatever everything happen
right here in places like Compton
poverty is extreme jobs are scarce and
one of every three black and Latino men
have or are serving prison time seven
and ten kids here grow up in homes
without a dad acacia is full of young
men looking for surrogate family and a
father figure to help them find their
way are you conscious with some of these
young guys look up to you like you're
just old this is a father figure and
what does that meet you I mean it means
a lot we like family this is like a
family I mean lots of me I love them
they love me we look out for each other
half of us ain't got parents a bus ain't
got nobody to give us nothing I'm 16 I
wouldn't tell anybody to do something I
wouldn't do I give them good and
positive things but sometime maybe like
me we finna go do this or I tell them
the consequences you own man you do what
you want to do but I've let them know
the law no more the law than them cuz
I've been to prison and to law libraries
and stuff here in gangland Street law
reigns boy bangers learned early on that
conflict is resolved through violence
so you have to Friday some you don't
play with we don't want to kill each
other whatever after little fist fight
so they're gonna take Hanson sober with
if he Musa Mota can fight again but I
think he had enough